foreign
I'm reporting here live from the Straz
Center in Tampa Florida where theophon
just put on three straight sold out
shows at this very theater each one in
front of 2600 people I was lucky enough
to be in attendance on night one here in
Tampa and with dozens of shows still
remaining on the return of the Rat tour
it only felt right to make this video
fully recapping what it's really like to
see Theo Von live very few people in
comedy have more loyal supporters than
Theo Von but for years now there's been
a growing sentiment among some comedy
fans who seem to enjoy Theo's humor more
in podcast settings as opposed to his
actual stand-up that statement may seem
harsh at first but it makes a lot more
sense once you consider just how
brilliant theovan is talking off the
cuff during interviews not to mention
the enormous difference in the amount of
podcast content that's available to fans
compared to onstage video Theo you're
from Louisiana what do you think about
this guy yeah
um when you said Landry I knew he was
from there that's the only place I've
ever heard that name what part are you
from I'm from Houma oh yeah yeah dude
home is a good place really
it's a good place to have a friend it's
real soft down there the land is real
soft it's like you could be talking to
somebody and then you just [__]
and people are so nice they'll listen as
they just [__] go
they just sink into the ground I'd love
to stay but
this is why I had some mixed emotions
heading into Theo's live show last
weekend I knew it was going to be funny
but there was still some suspense in the
air just to see how Theo's new hour
would compare to the classic Theo clips
that we all know and love what in the
hell is Theo I Got My Ticket super last
minute from a third party site and ended
up having to pay over a hundred bucks a
pop so I'm not sure what the price was
when they first came out between the
hundred dollar tickets and preparing to
pay theater drink prices once we arrived
this was turning into quite the fancy
night on the town so before we left I
had to shave my balls this video is
brought to you by manscaped and their
performance package 4.0 the ultimate
Men's Grooming and hygiene bundle the
performance package 4.0 includes a ton
of great manscaped products like the
lawnmower 4.0 the new weed whacker 2.0
knows an ear trimmer and two products I
never knew I needed until right now the
crop preserver ball deodor and the crop
retriever ball toner spray which is
super cool both the lawnmower 4.0 and
the weed whacker 2.0 are completely
cordless and were created to reduce
grooming accidents plus both products
feature proprietary technology that
instantly helps reduce Nicks snags and
tugs bring your comfort to a whole new
level by visiting manscape.com today to
get 20 off plus free international
shipping when you use promo code joke
world at checkout that's 20 off plus
free shipping with promo code joke World
at manscapes.com
as far as the actual show goes right out
the gate Theo had everyone laughing
super hard at his opening joke and from
there it somehow just kept getting
better witnessing theovan performs stand
up live exceeded all of my expectations
by a mile he looked insanely comfortable
on stage at times it felt like he was
just having a funny conversation with
the crowd the entire set felt very loose
and very well orchestrated at the same
time which I think translates perfectly
with Theo's sense of humor and
consistently kept the audience on her
toes even with jokes that you think you
might see coming about typical
theotopics like gerbils or drugs he
would then start going off on a bunch of
different tangents stringing multiple
jokes together to catch everyone off
guard I'm not just saying this I think
this was the first time in my entire
life that I was at a comedy show and
physically leaned forward due to
laughter but there's something really
special about if there's somebody you
watch on Tick Tock and social media and
you enjoy him right there's something on
a podcast or something I've said in the
audience I've like sat in the audience
before and been like oh man this is so
cool I watch this guy I'm involved in
their life for this girl and then I get
to be in the same room as them part of
it does doesn't really matter what
they're saying like it'd be great if the
material is also great but just being in
the same room as them it's almost like
you get like a moment in reality like
it's cool it's cool they're always on a
screen right and then they're right
there it's like oh this is cool kind of
like you for me that's true right Theo
was on stage for a little over an hour
and the majority of his set revolved
around his experiences growing up plenty
of jokes related to his family going to
school and making friends which
obviously is stuff that is talked about
a lot on this past weekend but I can
honestly say that the majority of the
stories he told on stage were different
than the ones he shared on podcasts that
was definitely a pleasant surprise and
honestly a bit unexpected just when you
think about his latest Netflix special
which a lot of people felt like was
almost a retelling of all of his best
podcast stories just in stand-up form my
father was real old when I was born you
guys know that my dad was born in 1910.
my father was 70 when I was born he was
born in 1910 which is kind of crazy man
dude my grandfather was born in 1880.
yeah yeah
we didn't have any pictures of him
we
we had a description of my grandfather
framed on the wall
somebody wrote down what he looked like
and Mom framed it
and I'd go up by it and be like just
like him
I look just like him I get it when mom
dies okay I should also mention another
great part of the evening with seeing
Ari Madness before Theo went on start to
finish this show was hilarious theovan
has obviously been very popular amongst
comedy fans for a long time but right
now he seems to be popping off more than
ever really hitting a whole new level in
his career as an Entertainer if you're
able to see him live anytime soon I
would highly recommend it but if that's
not in the cards don't worry about it we
just posted a brand new theophon try not
to laugh video for you all to enjoy it
right here on joke world yeah have you
ever heard of like those old things like
you put a little nickel a couple nickels
and some pennies under your tongue you
can blow you know zero what the [__] and
what you could blow a Jewish guy yeah
oh
[Applause]
what are you trying to say dude
[Music]
oh my God
I love it theovan.com for tickets holy
[__]
at joke world
and that world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out